let's face facts there have been some
poor pricing decisions in the past many
of them but few enraged Gamers and
indeed the press as much as the
$1,199 RTX 480 the market could accept
the Halo pricing attached to the 490 a
Titan in all but name a properly huge
leap in GPU performance PC market is
used to price premiums at the very top
end but beyond that the precedent is
that as you go down the stack and less
performant gpus enter the market
relative value has to increase RTX 480
did not do that and there are scenarios
where in terms of price versus
performance the 4090 did proportionately
better that just shouldn't be happening
and compared to the prior RTX 3080 we
were looking at around 50% extra
performance for 70% more money that just
doesn't work work and so here we are
with the RTX 480 super which and let's
be honest here is essentially the same
thing as the RTX 480 nons super just
with a new paint job and some tiny spec
tweaks uh which do not make any
meaningful difference to Performance but
what you do get is a
$999 MSRP relative to the 490 then the
value proposition increases so in that
sense there is the argument that this is
the price point the 480 should have
launched with but on the flip side still
a big big increase over the 3080 and I
do think that as you hit the $1,000
threshold you're entering Halo territory
but as you'll see as good as the 4080
super is on its own terms it's not a
4090 and it's nothing like that specs
then here's what you get um there's no
shift to higher end silicon in the way
that 4070 TI super shifted from the ad
104 processor to the more performant ad
103 480 super sits on ad 103 as well
albeit a fully enabled rendition of that
silicon meaning there's the full
complement of
10,240 cuticles but it's a mere 5%
increase in compute power over the
standard RTX 480 augmenting this is the
fastest gddr 6X modules Nvidia could
find but we're still looking at just a
2.6% increase to memory bandwidth over
the vanilla 480 so um for review today
we have received two Renditions of the
RTX 480 super the Nvidia produced
Founders Edition and the isus tough
gaming version both of them operate to
reference specifications and to the best
of my testing produce essentially like
for- likee performance outside of margin
of error differences however In the
Flesh they are two very different
propositions the founders Edition card
uh from my perspective least is a no and
proposition it uses the exact same
cooler and overall design as the RTX 480
and RTX 490 meaning that you're getting
a very large triple slot layout with
impeccable industrial design and cool
and quiet operation in keeping with the
design changes made with the 4070 super
the new offering is pure black looking
absolutely terrific uh Power is
delivered via the usual 12vt high power
socket and video outputs consist of the
standard Nvidia complement three display
port 1.4 a and an HDMI 2.1 the assus
tough gaming version is frankly gigantic
348 mil long versus the 310 Ms of the
founders Edition a quad slot design with
a vast plainly visible heat sink but
relatively discret RGB lighting the
Shroud is plastic meaning it feels
cheaper to the touch than the Fe model
although the back plate is metal similar
to the Nvidia version the 12volt high
power socket is used for power delivery
but in addition to the three display
ports on the rear there are actually two
HDMI outputs up against the single one
on the founders Edition both of these
cards you know essentially the same in
terms of your gameplay experience and
both are available at MSRP so let's get
on to the meat and drink of this video
performance but I'm going to abbreviate
here to make the relevant points before
we move on to some more interesting
stuff all of the data is available in my
Euro gamer review um so yeah if you want
to check out those numbers they're there
for you link below I think for $1,000 up
4K is the focus for this one so that's
what I'm looking at here but the 1440p
and even 1080p numbers are in that text
review with all of the bar charts you
could possibly desire looking at Dying
Light 2 first as is tradition the RTX
480 and 480 super essentially
interchangeable from a performance
standpoint despite the spec boost
delivered by the Super upgrade but
what's surprising here is that the 490
is streets ahead with a 43.5% boost over
the 4080 super at least with a price cut
to $11,000 the super presents a better
balance of cost versus performance I
guess with a similar price point the
Radeon RX 7900 XTX looks to be roundly
beaten by the super with the Nvidia
product delivering Circa 25% more
performance as we shall see though team
red does have rasterization advantages
and it would be no surprise to see an
official price adjustment coming from
AMD in due course based on the overall
package uh cyberpunk 2077 operating in
pure RT mode here at Al for settings
with no upscaling an absolutely
punishing workout for any GPU up to and
including the RTX 4090 which only brings
home a 47 FPS average similar to Dying
Light the top end card still dominates
this time there's a 38 percentage point
lead problematic in terms of price
versus performance for a 480 at
$1,200 but less so for $1,000 4080 super
this game is a close collaboration
between Nvidia and CD project red so
there's little surprise in seeing how
optimal the GeForce cars perform
relatively to Radeon the 39% performance
Advantage is palpable and it remains in
the same ballp park no matter which
resolution you look at let's move on now
to remedies control which has proven
problem Matic multiple times over for
the 40 series as it seems to perform
disproportionately poorly compared to
4090 here the flagship is 46% faster
than the 480 super 49 points to the
better over the 480 nons super it's
results like this that hammered the
relatively poor value offered by the 480
at large 49% more performance for 33% of
extra cost made the 490 look like a
better deal remarkably so with the the
480 super survival at
$999 the 490 is basically 46 points
clear but you need to pay an extra 60%
cash money to enjoy those extra frames
still this is a big wing for the 4090
and in turn the relatively lackluster
4080 super showing means that it's lead
over XTX it's just 18% f-122 next and
yeah we'll inevitably move on to a newer
iteration of the Cod Master's racer at
some point but for now we're sticking
with the tried and tested rition of the
game which effectively follows the
established performance pattern nothing
noteworthy divides RTX 480 and super
while the 490 screams ahead with a 38o
lead meaning that no sustainable
overclocking will ever bring the 4080
super anywhere near it um f122 is a game
where amd's RT performance seems much
closer to Nvidia generally um the 480
super is only about 8 percentage points
ahead uh which means that the 7900 XTX
is offering up 92% of the 480 supers
through put on this particular title an
outlier but they do happen so that's the
general spread really and there are few
surprises here because we're essentially
rerunning prior analysis right the 4080
was always faster than 7900 XTX but the
490 always blew all of them away at
least now the notion of 490 delivering
better value is addressed I mean we are
still talking about $1,000 GPU I think
at this point I should remind you to
take a look at my 4070 TI super and 4070
super reviews um dlss and optimized
settings still make those 4K contenders
and yes the 4070 super is the place to
be if value is the be all and end all
for those looking for the Nvidia feature
set now let's talk rasterization where
we should expect to see the 7900 XTX
pull ahead of the 4080 super in pretty
much the same way way it exceeded 480
performance in Prior reviews again more
numbers over on Euro gamer more gpus
tested more resolutions but here are my
highlights for 4K gaming with the two
480s 4090 and XTX Hitman 3 as we know
staggeringly fast when its RT effects
are disabled to the point where well I'd
be personally playing this game with rt
enabled using dlss but it's still a
handsome game at Native 4k on otherwise
ultra settings and yes it's AMD friendly
with an excellent 20 percentage Point
advantage to the XTX up against 4080
super and even the XT not plotted here
is essentially delivering Circa 4080
superclass performance I couldn't detect
any difference between 4080 and super at
Native 4K but a 36 percentage point lead
for the 4090 is clearly significant even
so 7900 XTX has around 88% of the 1490s
raster performance a clear value win a
plag to rec PRM A favorite of mine at a
proper Next Generation Showcase in terms
of that lavish detail perhaps not
surprising that AMD continues to deliver
a lead over Nvidia here with RX 7900 XTX
essentially 12 1 half percentage points
clear of the 480 super 490 is
unassailable it's a 41 percentage points
clear of the 4080 super and 23% ahead of
the XTX it's a result so high I checked
it and double checked it but there it is
of course you're paying dearly for that
privilege assuming you can find a
reasonably priced 4090 in the first
place on the one hand the 4080 price cut
is a good thing on the other it is a bit
sad that $1,000 no longer buys you
absolute state-of-the-art class
performance returnal next we love the
game but we don't enjoy the in-game
stutter uh something which The Benchmark
has none of whatsoever once again am AMD
emerges triumphant within the 4080 class
pricing range with the customary
12-point lead over the the new super
once again there's basically no
difference between 4080 and 4080 super
which makes you wonder a little why
Nvidia added cuor and faster memory at
all when this is clearly more of a price
cut than a meaningfully different
product and with an agent Smith inspired
sound of inevitability 4090 is
Untouchable 29 Points clear of 4080
super 15 ahead of 7900 XTX and prepare
to hear a lot more of the number 29 by
the way
Miles Morales it's interesting as this
actually sees the 480 super score a rare
win over the XTX only 3 to 4% on average
but you know it is there regardless a
116 frames per second average looks
pretty good for 4080 super but the full
RT suite and 4K dlss quality mode isn't
far behind at 98 FPS meanwhile a 4.5
percentage point lead for the super over
the vanilla 4080 must be the biggest
differential spotted so far between two
very similar products but still
essentially unnoticeable during the Run
of play RTX 490 29 points ahead again uh
turning the screws on the 480 super we
return to control uh which you know
hopefully you know by now has this bizar
power sapping impact on Ada love lace
graphics cards that are not the RTX 490
with that in mind it's no real surprise
to see 7900 XTX um deliver a fivepoint
lead over 4080 super though I did expect
to more actually from this classic
banana skin test in the corridor of Doom
the gap between 480 and 480 super
exceeds the typical one to two-point
lead but 3.4% still borders on
irrelevance and yes it will come as
little surprised to see the 4090 beating
480 by you guessed it
29% cyberpunk 2077 on Ultra almost a
shame to play this one without raid
facing or even path tracing at this
class of Hardware given how
transformative those Technologies could
be uh but it does reveal a clear AMD
rasterization win with 7900 XTX a good
18% ahead though there are gains for the
4080 super over 4080 at 1080P and 1440p
multiple runs saw no real difference at
4K which is a bit baffling RTX 490 is
still triumphant with a 29% lead over
480 super but the 7900 XTX is closer to
the 4090 result than it is to 480 Super
Final rasterization test fors of horizon
5 no real surprises an AMD win again
though the four to five percentage point
lead isn't seeing the 7900 XTX at its
most competitive against the 480s
clearly uh once again and to the
surprise of nobody there's barely any
difference between 4080 and 4080 super
and the 409s dominance starts to erode
though it's still 26 points clear of
4080 super and 20 to 21 points ahead of
the 7900 XT you pay for what you get but
with both Nvidia and AMD at the ,000
level a proportionate value clearly
isn't with the 490 which is how things
should be so we've talked a lot about
value and we will again but there are
further topics I want to go over first
of all the idea that the 4080 in bracket
super can run the top tier Graphics
showcases with full path tracing and
secondly as per the 4070 super video to
put more basic functionality to the test
with a matched head-to-head with the
PlayStation 5 in areas where we can
quote unquote Benchmark the console with
PlayStation 5 effectively the Baseline
for tripa development is interesting to
see just how much raw performance you
get from 480 super in like for like
testing scenarios uh kicking off with a
PL to recm 480 supera delivers a 2.8
times performance multiplier up against
the PS5 rising to 3.2x if you swap out a
soo's upscaler for dlss Quality mode
which is using the same internal
resolution frame genen increases that
multiply P to 3.9x I mean the game looks
great of course uh but you have the
Headroom for ramping up features like
engaging RT Shadows or improved
upscaling quality levels or even native
res I also looked at 7900 XTX no FSR 2
support here so we can only judge on a
likeforlike basis uh a 3.1x boost over
PS5 on Match settings and on that same
basis we're essentially 10% faster than
4080 super here's an area of cyberpunk
27 77 Phantom Liberty I found where we
have a fixed resolution on PS5 and a
failure to meet the 30fps performance
Target this is RT mode with FSR 2
upscaling and local RT Shadows pretty
much straight three times performance
multiplier with 4080 Super Rising to
3.2x if you swap out FSR 2 quality mode
for its dlss equivalent slap frame gen
on top of that we're now at a 4.3 times
frame rate multiplier in this scene
swapping in the XTX on like for like
basis with PS5 2.5 times increase in
performance lower than plague tail but
remember we have rt on here not the
strongest suit for rdna A3 but really if
you're dropping a grand on a GPU
possibly you want the full fat
experience right so let's look at path
traced cyberpunk RT overdrive in the
challenging cherry blossom Marketplace
480 super plays 4090 both with
performance mode upscaling Ray
reconstruction and frame gen active 7
900 XTX is along for the ride on FSR 2
performance mode though obviously it has
no Ray reconstruction or frame genen
capabilities so we're stuck in 20 FPS
territory uh 480 is on a 78.6 FPS
average in this run but 4090 is a
remarkable 32 points clear across the
run at 104 FPS so yes fully path traced
cyberpunk is viable on the 4080 for sure
at
4K Allen wake 2 next and we'll follow
follow a similar pattern with our
testing this point in the forest during
chapter 2 causes frame rate drops on
PlayStation 5 just under its 30fps cap
so we can get an indicative view of how
much faster 480 super and 7900 XTX are
we have a tight lock on Match settings
here finding that 4080 super three times
faster overall rising to 3.1x when we
swap out FSR 2 balance mode for its dlss
equivalent there's frame Gen 2 of course
which in combination with dlss upscaling
gives us a 4.2 times boost 7900 XTX can
be tested at fully matched PS5 settings
and there we get an excellent 3.2x
multiplier it's around six points clear
a 480 super like for like though but
obviously 480 super has more options but
what about path tracing then again
Nvidia has the advantage of frame gen
and Ray reconstruction along with
improved image quality via dlss spatial
upscaling but here's how the three-way
looks a 7 .6 FPS average on the 480
super uh almost forgot the super there
rising to 94.4 FPS on 490 a nonon 34
Point increase the frame rate on 480 is
fine but latency is noticeable to the
point I'd consider tweaks to resolution
down to 1800p or perhaps a move to
optimize settings to boost performance
and lower lag but if you want all the
bling at reconstructed 4K there it is uh
XTX is only at 20 FPS uh but clearly
these path Trace titles aren't built for
AMD I don't want you to think that a
poor experience is all you can get with
this game path tracing is beautiful but
medium settings is essentially PS5
quality mode a design Target for remedy
in looking great and if you switch to
those settings we're up to a 108 FPS
average and it's still stunning with
plenty of overhead available if you want
to increase settings still further so
that's two out of our three titles from
our best game Graphics of 2023 now how
about the winner Avatar frontiers of
Pandora an AMD sponsored title No lless
the settings don't give much away but
Hardware raate tracing is used in this
game I'm using 4K dlss quality mode on
Nvidia and AMD FSR 2 quality mode uh on
the XTX frame gen via FSR 3 is available
but even without it's still looking
highly performant on this class of
Hardware an 87 FPS average on 4080 Super
Rising to 117 FPS on the 490 another 34
Point boost XTX is at a 74 FPS average
so trailing the pack but still offering
85% of the 480 supers performance and
obviously highly viable for a 4K
experience so dropping $1,000 on a GPU
does open up all of those topend
experiences with no visual compromises
or very few 4090 still outpaces 480
super by a good third though but at
least the 4080 super is proportionately
better value got to say though we can't
ignore that even 4070 super at 600 of
your us bucks can still run those games
and they still look good you just need
to accept a certain level of compromise
but still value eh let's talk about that
I've noticed that dollars per frame
based on a multi-game average is a
comparative measure used by some of the
PC press and I like it I think it's a
Fant fantastic at a glance look at value
with much to commend it obviously those
results are going to be defined a great
deal by Myriad factors including the
choice of game how many RT benches are
included on one side and how many Ultra
performant eorts are on the other still
I thought I'd give it a go right and
this table is the result six RT games in
the average here eight raster but what's
this normalized average result then so
averaging a bunch of averages based on a
nonlinear scale frames per second
doesn't make sense to me and I wondered
what to do about that so what did I do I
asked Developers for their input and
this comment in particular stood out to
me if you average two games at 30 FPS
and 300 FPS the first game will become
insignificant while in real life 0 to 30
FPS will be far more noticeable than 270
to 300 FPS or the other way around 10
games at 30 FPS will have as much of an
impact as one game at 300 FPS their
suggestion normalization average all the
scores for a particular game from all of
the gpus tested then assign a variance
to that average for each card this
eliminates the Distortion I just
described enabling a more consistent
normalized cost per frame whichever
calculation method you choose both of
them are here the evidence is pretty
clear when it launched at a massively
misjudged $1,200 480 barely offered the
same value as the Halo 490 and in some
metrics it would obviously be worse
something that was obviously the case
when we tested individual titles and
yeah looking at the RTX 3080 the cost
per frame values shows that relative
value only slightly tips towards the
4080 super priced at $1,000 but I guess
at least we're looking at something
fairer than the prior status quo in
effect this looks very much like the
kind of topend pricing stress topend
pricing that the 4080 should have had at
large if you're looking for
proportionately better value for an
Nvidia card 4070 super is clearly worth
taking a look at based on the table here
just bear in mind that for those totally
uncompromised experiences 4080 super
represents what you might consider a
threshold to making that happen
effectively just my subjective view
though I'm still te team optimized
settings just to make that clear in
summary then 4080 super does what it
needs to do in terms of delivering the
kind of price performance we didn't get
at launch similar to the RTX 470 TI
super kind of feels that the package
that should have been there back in the
day expensive but not outrageous
egregiously so as the vanilla 4080 was
at
$1,200 thing is it's arriving 14 months
on from the 480s launch while they is a
superior level of proportionate value
compared to the rightly celebrated RTX
3080 it's not that much better and it's
still hard not to feel that this is
still a pretty steep asking price for an
at class product that isn't a TI by the
way and I guess while there is now a gap
uh in pricing terms for a 4080 TI with
the AI boom I do wonder whether we'll
actually get to see one still that's the
end of this video so please do like
subscribe share and ring the bell for
whatever Rand random prompts may or may
not appear on your phone a DF supporter
program join us for access to our
amazing Community high quality video
downloads Early Access to dfet weekly
and other content plus regular behind
the scenes updates from the team oh yeah
and store. digitalfoundry Donnet check
that out for a look at our range of
quality merchandising but that's all for
me for now thanks as ever for watching
and supporting digital
Foundry